Now that we have
found the solution
to the linear least mean
squares estimation problem,
it is time to offer
a few comments,
make some observations,
and provide some insights.
A first important
observation is the following.
In order to implement
this estimator,
you do not really need
to know everything
about the distribution
of X and Theta.
The only thing that
you need to know
is the mean of the two random
variables that are involved,
the variance of X, and the
covariance of Theta with X.
So it's only a few pieces
of information that we need,
and that means
that we do not need
to be so careful about modeling
in a particular problem,
as long as we know what
the means, variances,
and covariances are.
This is a very
desirable property,
because it tells us that
this could be simpler
to implement in the real world.
Now let us start looking at
the form of the solution,
and let's try to give
some interpretation.
Suppose that the correlation
coefficient is positive.
Then what does
this estimator do?
It starts with a
baseline estimate,
which is the expected
value of Theta.
And then provides us
with a correction term
that's based on the data.
In particular, if
it happens that we
see an observation that's larger
than expected, in that case,
our estimate is going
to be above the expected
value of Theta.
So we started with
our baseline estimate,
but if we get a big
observation, then our estimate
will also be large.
And conversely, if X happened
to be on the lower side,
below the expected
value, then our estimate
would also be below the
expected value of Theta.
Of course, there's
an analogous story.
If rho was negative,
then a same argument
would apply, except
that it would
work in the opposite direction.
When rho is negative,
if we see a large X,
then we will come up with
a low estimate for Theta.
Let us look at another
special case now.
Suppose that the
rho is equal to 0,
X and Theta are uncorrelated.
Then this last term here
disappears, and in this case,
our estimate is going to be just
the expected value of Theta.
In other words, our
estimate doesn't
make any use of the data.
Essentially what's happening
is that a linear estimator
exploits the correlation
between the two random variables
to come up with an estimate.
But if the two random
variables are uncorrelated,
then [there is]
nothing that it can
do, and it does not
give us anything useful.
It just reports back the
expected value of Theta.
Let us now look at the
mean square error that's
obtained when we implement
this linear estimator.
Let us write down what
this expression is.
And to keep things
simple, let us
assume that we have 0
means and 0 variances.
So just for the purposes of
this derivation and to simplify
the algebra, we will work
with the 0 mean case.
So in this case,
what we have-- let
me first write Theta, and
then put here the estimator.
The estimator is rho times
sigma Theta, sigma X times X.
Basically, I took
this formula, but I
put 0s for the expected values.
Now let us expand
this quadratic.
We obtain the expected
value of Theta squared.
That's the variance of Theta,
since we assume 0 means.
And the variance is the square
of the standard deviation.
Then we have a cross term.
Is going to be twice
the expectation
of the product of
Theta with this.
Now we can take out
this constant outside
of the expectation,
so it's 2 rho sigma
Theta, sigma X. And
then we are going
to have the expected
value of Theta times X.
Because we assume 0 means, the
expected value of Theta times X
is the covariance
of Theta and X.
And the covariance is
rho sigma Theta, sigma X.
And finally, we have a last
term, which is rho squared,
sigma Theta squared,
divided by sigma X squared
times X squared.
We have an expected
value, so that's
the expected value of X squared,
which is just the variance of X
or sigma X squared.
OK, this looks like a
big mess, but in fact, we
get nice cancellations.
This term cancels
with that term.
We notice that we have
sigma Theta squared
in each one of those terms,
so we can factor them out.
And then here we have minus 2
rho squared plus rho squared.
When we subtract
those two terms we're
left just with a minus
rho squared term.
So after you do that
algebra carefully,
you find that the answer
takes a very simple form.
It's 1 minus rho squared
times the variance of Theta.
I should add here that
this formula remains valid,
even without the assumption
that X and Theta have 0 means.
What's the
interpretation of this?
The variance of Theta describes
the initial uncertainty
we have about Theta.
But after we carry
out the estimation,
the uncertainty
gets reduced, and it
gets reduced by
a certain factor.
What is this factor?
If rho is equal to 0,
than this coefficient is 1
and we do not have any
variance reduction.
After all, when
rho is equal to 0,
this estimator is
not very useful.
It doesn't help us
estimate Theta better.
So the expected value
of the squared error
is the same as the
variance of Theta.
On the other hand,
when rho is large,
then this term
here becomes small,
and this means that the
mean squared error is small.
In fact, there is an extreme
case that's interesting, namely
if rho is equal to
1 in absolute value.
So if the random variables
are perfectly correlated,
then this term here
becomes 0, and the mean
squared estimation error is 0.
Which essentially
means that our estimate
is going to be equal
to the unknown value.
So the special case of a unit
correlation, in absolute value,
corresponds to a case where we
can perfectly estimate Theta,
using a linear estimator.
So to summarize, the
correlation coefficient
plays a crucial role in linear
least squares estimation.
It determines the
form of the estimator,
and also, it determines how
much the uncertainty in Theta
will be reduced through
the process of estimation.